bonjour et merci d'être andy rihs en
direct avec nous alors on commence avec
cette question par rapport à ceux
communiqués dès fédérations est ce que
vous estimez vous aussi qu'il s'agit
d'une fermeture déguisée
écoutez d'abord bonjour merci de
m'interviewer une peut-être pas une
fermeture déguisée mais il va falloir un
peu plus de maturité dans la gestion de
la crise à cet évident peut pas
continuer avec des emplâtres sur des
jambes de bois il y à il ya une
nébuleuse à la fois au niveau de l'ut
des problèmes sanitaires et il ya aussi
une nébuleuse au niveau du problème
économique tout en attendant la vague
émotionnelle que l'on peut attendre pour
les fêtes de fin d'année vous verrez ça
sera pas triste du tout dans leur
communiqué les fédérations déplore que
les effectifs de policiers déployés pour
faire respecter le couvre-feu n'est pas
plutôt été mobilisé pour effectuer des
contrôles dans les établissements et
ainsi permettre leur ouverture vous êtes
d'accord avec ça mais écoutez la
profession s'est engagée à prendre des
mesures toutes les mesures barrières si
vous voulez et toutes les restrictions
utile il est évident que la crise doit
être perçue avec beaucoup de maturité et
sécurisé disons à la fois le public et
nos clients mais de là si vous voulez à
extrapoler et à tous les deux à un mois
ou deux mois essayait d'havré inventé le
fil à couper le beurre
là je pense que c'est quand même un
petit peu triste de voir c'est justement
cette immaturité dans la gestion des
crises est ce que vous estimez vous
aussi qu' il y avait une limite dans les
mesures mises en place dans ces
établissements pour faire barrage à la
pandémie à la propagation de l'épidémie
ou pour vous c'était suffisant écoutez
personnellement je pense que c'était
suffisant alors qu'il faille
ponctuellement pendant un délai si vous
voulez suffisamment parce que il faut
quand même que le corps médical si vous
voulez et tout ce qui touche aux
sanitaires soient prioritaires on peut
pas quand même quand on voit les
chiffres exponentielle bien que là aussi
il va falloir
maturité pour analyser les chiffres
puisque chaque fois que l'on change de
chaîne de télévision on a des
intervenants qui vous donne des chiffres
qui vous donne des appréciations qui
sont complètement voir opposer les
autres on vient à ces annonces donc dû
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
font ceux d'alliés de solidarité
renforcée exonération des charges est
tendue et prêts garantis par l'état
rallonger est-ce que ça va vous aider
dans votre secteur à faire face dans
l'urgence on peut considérer que l'état
fait le nécessaire
aujourd'hui nous allons nous inscrire
dans le temps c'est à dire que je ne
vois pas comment
même si on nous amenons ce vaccin vous
le savez qu'on n'a pas trouvé les
amériques des vaccins bordé pour des
virus divers et variés dans l'histoire
et même si on nous annonçait vaccia je
ne vois pas dans l'est dans les deux ans
à venir qu'on puisse revenir à une
situation dans la normalité
il va donc falloir sortir des emplâtres
des jambes de bois et enfin une
politique d aide qui soit une politique
structurée réfléchi et qu'ils puissent
faire face malheureusement c'est la
profession des métiers du tourisme qui
est le plus touché
et avec ça on ne pensait que le
l'autorisent n'avait pas une incidence
très fort sur l'économie française et au
delà même planétaire
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que quand
m'autorise me va presque tout va et que
quand il ne va pas écouté j'ai beaucoup
de beaucoup de réflexions sur mes
collègues parisiens mes collègues de la
montagne les mots collecte de lait des
grandes agglomérations qui je pense vont
peut-être être vraiment très touchés qui
aurait pu imaginer que paris vivent un
tel une telle situation
est ce que vous craignez finalement
qu'on arrive à al annonce d'un
confinement comme au printemps dernier
je ne pense pas et je n'espère pas parce
que recombiner vaudrait dire des mesures
très particulière et qui pourrait
engager lourdement l'économie du pays
pour les années à venir
déjà la crise que nous vivons mal
engagée à mon avis sur du court moyen
terme
imaginez vous si l'on reconfirme comment
l'engagement peut-être et puis y at-il
aujourd'hui peut-on aujourd'hui cette
crise est hors norme peut-on aujourd'hui
trouver une véritable appréciation de
cette crise et y apporter les réponses
c'est pas encore je crois suffisamment
abouti pour qu'on puisse trouver les
vrais field le conducteur de cette crise
bien merci beaucoup jean pierre pin et
dit je rappelle que vous êtes vice
président du cercle des grandes maisons
quand merci pour vos réponses
merci